plateau avec nous tu alignes houjian
bonjour tallinn vous revenez d'une
mission pour france 24 dans le donbass
vous étiez notamment dans cette ville de
bac mouthe qui sont ses habitants qui
refusent aujourd'hui de fuir ses
habitants on les a rencontrés avec mes
collègues achraf habillé deluxe ragots
la plupart du temps ce sont des
personnes qui sont en situation de
grande précarité
qui vivent dans des hlm qui n'ont
généralement pas de voiture pour pouvoir
partir ni un autre logement en fait
simplement pour aller vivre ailleurs en
ukraine il y avait aussi énormément de
personnes âgées qui ont les mêmes
difficultés financières mais qui aussi
n'ont parfois tout simplement pas la
santé pour partir je vous propose de
regarder un extrait de notre reportage à
barr doute
si certains civils décide de rester
d'autres n'ont tout simplement pas le
choix
maman lève toi tu te plaît
la mère de valérie et handicapées
qu'est-ce que je peux faire qu'est ce
qu'elle peut faire ou pouvons-nous nous
enfuir monfils qu'est ce qui te
préoccupe
laisse tomber c'est juste à propos de
toi
qu'est ce que je peux dire
comment je peux attirer l'attention sur
ce qui s'est passé ici qu aider
l'ukraine
les bombardements sont quotidiens
pratiquement dans le donbass tallinn
certes la population à la ciste
impuissante à l'avancé des russes qui
est indéniable dans le donbass
quel est l'état d'esprit de la
population on a vu cette femme en pleurs
et de la tristesse de la résignation
aussi oui beaucoup de tristesse mais il
ya aussi parfois des habitants qui
refusent catégoriquement de partir on
parle avec une mine humanitaire qui nous
expliquait qu' ils sont parfois ils ont
la crainte que leurs appartements soit
par exemple cambriolée durant leur
départ ou bien que la situation en fait
à doit être un peu la même ailleurs en
ukraine donc il faut arriver à ce stade
vraiment dramatique ou leur appartement
sont frappés par des tirs de missiles
pour qu'ils aient envie finalement de
partir et weave ses habitants qui sont
excédés on a suivi des pompiers qui
livrait en eau des populations qui n'ont
plus accès donc à lomé non plus au gaz
ni à l'électricité depuis des mois ses
habitants il n'en peut plus et je vous
propose de regarder un extrait d'un des
reportages que l'on a tourné où on s'est
retrouvé tout d'un coup au milieu de
bombardements et c'est en fait le pain
quotidien de ses habitants désormais ses
habitants se regroupent à la hâte pour
récupérer de l'eau potable mais les
manques se font toujours sentir ils ont
coupé tout le gaz tout bloquer et c'est
tout qu'est ce qu'il croit le président
et vince qui est ce qu'il pense avec sa
tête ou avec son derrière
pourquoi il a tout coupé
si quelqu'un se trouve dans les couloirs
où les appartements décents d ici les
bombardements s'intensifient
oh
une bombe à sous-munitions a créé l onde
de choc
oui une ouragans
donc voilà ce qui était frappant avec
ses habitants c'est qu'il n'était même
pas dans une espèce de frayeur ou
quelques chèques eu peur que ce soit il
était plutôt dans une profonde colère
après les bombardements on entendait les
habitants ont crié mais pourquoi est ce
qu'ils continuent de nous tirer dessus
et ce qu'il n'y a aucun accord possible
avec les russes vous entendiez également
une habitante qui demandait confirmation
auprès d'un pompier pour savoir s'il
s'agissait de bombes à sous-munitions
c'était bien le cas le bombes à
sous-munitions ce sont des conteneurs
qui sont remplis de mini-bombes qui qui
sont largués de façon très aléatoire et
sur des surfaces très élargie dont elles
ont des conséquences dramatiques pour
les populations
et voilà on maintenant c'est le pain
quotidien en fait tout simplement de ses
habitants qui sortent simplement
quelques minutes pour essayer de
récupérer un peu d'eau et qui se
retrouvent voilà le reportage montre
bien ça le chaos maintenant il arrive à
n'importe quel moment de la journée et
ses bombardements ils se sont
drastiquement intensifier nanou on était
à sauvian ce que bart gouttes et cravate
au ska jazz cela une semaine mais depuis
les bombardements ils sont de plus en
plus fréquents parce que la ville
stratégique de l'iscid chance que dans
le donbass est tombé et que ces villes
maintenant elle représente l'objectif
principal des russes pour qu'ils
puissent avancer leur objectif principal
étant la conquête de tous le dombass
d'ici la fin de l'été merci beaucoup
tallinn ou de gens pour votre témoignage
très concret et très humain tout
ses vidéos et ses reportages son rapt à
retrouver sur notre site france24 point
com et c'est aussi l'occasion pour nous
de saluer nos équipes nos envoyés
spéciaux en ukraine leur travail bien
sûr et essentiel pour vous informer de
manière indépendante merci encore
tallinn